hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play though
why not if not not the white knight it's
not the opposite of Batman here it is
white knight annoying her got it okay
what I got I just um what is that sound
what is going on I have no idea anyway
there's some weird stuff going on in the
background here anyway I just did
something but I don't know what I did I
went in this room and I got something I
don't know if I've missed something or
huh somebody said you turned boxes
upside down to get light bulbs and that
just sounds like ridiculousness I don't
think that's anything I think you're all
lying to me you wouldn't do that would
you
you wouldn't lie to me right now you
would lie to me you would so lie to me
it exploit me use me anything over here
know anything can I move these okay so
obviously don't go that way
I got no mementos and I have a key that
goes to the downstairs section verses
down stores downstairs door anyway then
in there it's not what does that sound
it sounds like an alarm and a whistle
mixed together and some did diabolical
demon demon baby here's some weird oh
yeah oh yeah this downstairs area that I
didn't go down before man I tell you the
atmosphere with the atmosphere I looked
up and I saw beware Italy
anything under the stairs I just got a
chill go double one is expecting
something I tell you the atmosphere in
this game no wonder it's such a highly
reviewed custom story it's pretty good
Asian wards doors locked as dr. Sophia
instructed restoration was left
half-finished and it was nearly
impossible to use patient words she said
patients with crafts should continue to
work so I took the files to examine
patient tomato dish the only to somehow
have them continue to the work that was
left half-finished John Barker Richard
Quinton Thomas redwood David written
potable read and read the dollar due to
bad handwriting
okay game or batteries okay someone said
turn a box update on hood will fail you
lie to me huh yeah nope Oh what is a box
no that didn't work people lie to me get
out of the way chair oh you're you don't
patient Winkie why all the patients have
wings I'm funny damn it oh this looks
good
it won't budge this will
oh look another bathroom I like it two
bathrooms the bathrooms are my fav eNOS
they're not that was sarcasm by the why
they do not like the bathrooms bathrooms
and horror games are never good I don't
know what it is oh yeah see I don't know
what that thing is it won't budge just
like this every other door in the wall
okay is it patient war is hung on one
second let me check these four yeah well
move huh these won't move but the other
ones won't budge what's the deal I want
I want I want
come here thing I will not name draw
fire hax ha ha ha let me use it come on
let me ask you a question come here come
here just gonna fight man I tell you the
atmosphere in this one is really good
really good really really good oh I'm so
strong okay I made the mattress D
materialize into the air I don't know if
there's gonna be any in anything in E&E
of these maybe I'm just wasting my time
probably if won't budge this one will
and I gotta check this again just cuz
I'm OCD like that or something
that one will budge
[Music]
okay nothing nothing good matter
oh hello let me guess the firewall the
flower ba-bow hey I so strong and
handsome and generally amazing generally
not specifically but generally lock is
broken just like your face the judge
seen was seeming unrelated to the issue
like it had nothing to do with people's
lives all mr. Lawrence wanted to do was
throwing off the responsibility of
someone else possibly the first time he
really wanted to kill someone
well maybe not the first time I'm
guessing that's a judge in this guy's
case
oh I'm outside what
I probably shouldn't let me outside I'm
crazy nuts all further derp derp derp
derp baby I'm just gonna make whose
lines where references all day life but
it does add a baby but I've done it done
a baby but see if anybody gets them
probably not a lot of you but if you do
you're one of the cool kids hey where'd
my fire axe go can I usually go rah rah
got it oh haha biznitch ha another
psycho crazy person I won't kill your
family I swear what's going on here
I'm not going forward into that blood oh
I hate this it's so no no no no
seriously this reminds me a cry fear so
[Music]
much it really really does it really
does Wow well I haven't I played
although you know I do not want to I
will not eat grain anything okay come on
come on you want some of me after you
buddy
a few bring it raaah that's why I
thought thought you were super I knew it
that is my serious face
all right let's see
hi
I knew you weren't to be trusted
no no Hey what duck whoa hey what done
what the hell that's all right
what that whoa okay never mind you just
do your little light show there and I'm
gonna gonna go on to UM no arm oval over
here
we're sanity and rainbows florists like
butterflies in the wind
Hey look wait is this what you were
talking about fluke
hi don't know oh hi what the hell you
all lied to me you lied to me
ah you all oh ok not going that way just
yet there might be some other cool stuff
here
no those lies all lies oh saying those
lies I was lying to you that's what I do
I'm a liar me no likey that ok
my head hit onto that light up there got
it and the nowhere key your nowhere he
shut up
I'm go it's literally a nowhere
woah man they put a lot of effort into
this custom story no whoa whoa no whoa
Nelly whoa boy
easy on the crazy there man
like seriously if you haven't watched my
cry fear Let's Plays on go watch them
and then watch this cuz you could see
like I'm not saying that one drew
inspiration from the other I'm just
saying that insanity apparently has some
pretty common themes across the board
here yeah
they're all group goopy and crunchy
crunchy I invented a new word crunchy
trademark so where am I going from here
aha that's where I am go from here see
huh I can't I fruit yo if I didn't know
any better I think that I am blue don't
fall don't fall don't fall don't look
down
looking down is bad though you know this
bad news
oh ho here we go no ha ha Oh what this
leak throw skills yes huh jump ow
that's ok just made everything thematic
thematic th e ma GIC k TC @ TI c
thematic uh I never claimed to win any
spelling bees was a good wait which way
what what which way did I just come down
from oh come on oh damn it I'm going
down the same way RNA I didn't pay
attention we expect me to look which way
did I just come down from which they
look exactly the same
oh this is the one damn it I'm an idiot
idiot I'm an idiot what it ha who gets
turned around that easily who who gets
fooled
that's simply I am an ahjumma incident
yet I'm a new to me it intimate I DJ I
am I t and jiminy out I am i NIT in
German in it meaning in it you think I
went through that fog of death and
redness that place was downright lovely
[Music]
no no no wait am I could have sworn
something goes up here this game doesn't
even feel like amnesia oh my oh lordy oh
lordy Lou hi what are you doing there
you're coming with me
we're sorry you're leaving behind like
seriously the changes they made make
this game seemed unbelievably different
it just feels like an entirely different
beast something done chase me isn't it
something's gonna chase me something's
gonna change me hey John John I know
what's in here is that a hand
what how good hey what patient number
six mr. Jamestown cause of death loss a
pod found when before noon around 11
a.m. found where in one of the locked
rooms near the morgue door was locked
from the inside which leads us to
believe he locked himself in last night
two janitors body was found in patient
six was missing as far as we know
patient killed the janitor with a knife
he stole from the morgue and then locked
himself in a room patient was delusional
aggressive when he first came however
his rate of hallucinations was
decreasing although he never married he
was hallucinating a dead wife called
Maria and often talked about her with
the janitor that's why we were observing
his relationship with the janitor in
hope it would turn into friendship the
janitor and patient were not close but
they were often talking to each other
when we found mr. Jamestown he was
already dead from blood loss his fingers
and left hand were cut with presumably
with presumably saying knife he used to
murder the janitor I wonder why he did
this to himself after killing him we
still don't know why he killed the
janitor why he locked himself in why he
cut his fingers and why and left hand as
he didn't have any suicidal tendencies
all right so that's obviously not me I
thought I might have been me for a
second there but I am not dead as far as
I know I might be
oh no choices secret I was dead the
whole time all right I am actually all
out of time so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos I've done and as always I will
see you in the next video bye bye
[Music]
terrible design depart routes go nowhere
Oh God Oh
[Music]